Further if you read the Ramayan in ayod
volume number two chapter number 20
verse number 29 when Ram is sent for
banas 14 years and when his mother asked
him that why don't you take the
provision he said I'm going to the
forest for banas 14 years I will give up
my meat and only have fruits and
vegetable give up the meat that means
Ram used to have meat. So when your
scripture says Ram used to have meat,
why can't you and I have meat? What we
realize that many of the Hindus they
were being impressed by the other
religions like Janism etc. That's the
reason they started following their
philosophy and many religions like
Janism they believe that we should not
kill animals because killing any life is
prohibited. At that time they did not
know that even the plants have life.
Today science has advanced and we have
come to know that the plants have got
life. So the logic of not giving killing
living creature is falsified.
You cannot survive without killing
anyone anything alive. Even when we
breathe, when we breathe, we are killing
hundreds and thousands of germs and
bacteria, millions full day when we
breathe in and out even they have got
life. So if anyone says you can survive
without killing any other creature, any
other germ or bacteria, it's impossible.
As the Hindu scripture says that God has
created some to be eaten and some as
eater. So God has his creation. So what
God has permitted there's no problem.
Then they have changed. You know
the plant
they cannot feel pain. Now there's
difference of opinion.
Some scientists say plant can feel pain
some cannot feel pain. But okay maybe we
agree with the with the scientist
since the plant don't have a nervous
system and the brain like human beings
have or the animals have. They cannot
feel pain. But we surely know that
plants when we touch some of the plants
close they're reflexes.
So even if we agree that plants can't
feel pain. So the logic says the
non-Muslims or the gs will say the plant
has got less senses. Therefore killing a
plant is less a crime as compared to
killing animal. Even if I agree with
them for sake of argument that the
plants have got two senses less as
compared to the animals. So I ask them a
question. Suppose if I have a brother
who born deaf and dumb, cannot hear,
cannot speak. He has two senses. And
after he grows up, if somebody comes and
kills him, will I go and tell the judge
me Lord give the murderer less
punishment because my brother had two
senses less. Will I tell that? In fact,
I'll tell the judge he has killed my
brother Masum poor man had two senses
less. Give him a bigger punishment.
In Islam, it does not work like that
with the two cents is more two cents is
less. Islam what our creator almighty
God has created for a purpose as long as
you follow the rule of god it's allowed
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter number two eat of the good
things we have provided so whatever is
good you can have whatever almighty god
our creator the creator of all the
universe the creator of all the living
creature in the world whatever he makes
a law as long long as you follow that
law because he is our creator there's no
issue we should not go against the law
of the creator
and
that's the reason we Muslims we follow
the law of the creator the creator what
he has done those animal he has created
to be eaten like the cattle they
multiply in large numbers you can see
they multiply In large numbers those
which a creator did not want to eat they
multiply very slowly.
If every human being in the world
decides today we be vegetarian
then there'll be overpopulation of
cattle. Now your problem of over
population of human being there'll be
millions and billions of more cattle in
the world. If we don't utilize these
animal for our food, there'll be
overpopulation of cattle. As far as I'm
concerned, I personally have no problem
if a non-Muslim does not have non-wage
food. Like where I was born in India,
if the Indians don't have non-wage food,
I have no problem. Because if every
Indian start having non-wage food, the
price of mutton, chicken, beef will go
high. So for me, I'm happy. But if
someone objects that it's a sin, eating
mutton, eating beef, eating chicken,
that's the reason I give this answer.
Otherwise, you don't want to eat.
There's no problem. It's not compulsory.
You can be a very good Muslim even by
being a pure vegetarian. Only give this
answer when they have the wrong
philosophy that
so this replies
to the 10th most common question asked
by non-Muslim.